hello and welcome to the third part on
on the measure of intelligence by
Francois Shola now this is a multi-part
series if you haven't seen the first two
parts I recommend to watch at least one
of them they're somewhat overlapping but
we've basically gone over the history of
intelligence measurement and the
foundations of what a measurement for
intelligence for an AI system should
look like and today we're going to get
into the formal definition of the
intelligence that surely proposes right
here so this sentence here pretty much
sums up what kind of what we're
interested in the intelligence of a
system is a measure of its skill
acquisition efficiency over a scope of
tasks with respect to priors experience
and generalization difficulty so these
are the things that we've established so
far
basically the intelligence of a system
that's the thing we want to measure
right is a measure of its skill
acquisition efficiency so how fast does
it acquire new skills important here is
that we are measuring it over a scope of
tasks so it's not arbitrary skills it is
a scope that we define and this is going
to be mostly the human scope the tasks
the scope of tasks that humans can solve
and are sort of different at and what we
need to factor in our priors which is
what is already built in to a system
because that doesn't count as
intelligence that's already built in if
your ability to solve a problem is
already built in to you you don't have
to use intelligence to solve the problem
second experience if you have had lots
and lots and lots of experience at the
particular task you're asked to solve
you don't have to use intelligence you
can simply rely on your experience and
the third is generalization difficulty
and that's a property of the task so if
the task is very difficult to generalize
so if it's very difficult if the task
itself is very difficult
then achieving a good score at it should
count as having higher intelligence if
all other things are equal so this is
going to be the basis and we're today
we're going to or we're going to watch
Shirley define these things into a
basically into a number that can give us
the intelligence of an of any system
with respect to these things okay so
that's the program for today if you like
content like this share it out and tell
all your friends and leave a like so
that YouTube knows that you do like it
okay so the conceptualization of the
entire system is like this there is a
task and we're going to consider a
series of tasks of course but if we just
look at one task in our scope there is
the task and the task outputs these
situations okay which in a machine
learning term these are like your
training examples right and on the other
side there is the intelligent system
okay now the intelligent system in a
pure machine learning side you would
factor this as the task gives the
intelligent system a something like a
training sample or in reinforcement
learning it would be something like a an
observation and the intelligent system
you know gives something back like a
response here we have a kind of a
in-between step the intelligent system
doesn't actually give back the response
to the situation the intelligent system
generates a skilled program so the
intelligent system will generate a
program that can map the situation to a
response and that skill program should
be able to run on its own okay so in the
classic machine learning sense if we
look at supervised learning for example
the intelligent system would be the
would be like a ResNet ResNet plus SGD
okay that is an intelligent system and
if it is output to is it is able to
generate a skill
program so during training what happens
during training during training the
intelligent system is able to intervene
in the skill program at each step so the
situation comes in and then the skill
program does something but the
intelligent system can at any point it
can kind of intervene and update the
skill program and generate a new skill
program for the next step right the so
there's a situation the skill program
gives a response and the task gives
feedback in form of a score in machine
learning terms this would be your
training sample your training sample
comes in your neural network gives a
response which are the log 'its of the
classes right then the task gives a
score to that which in the supervised
learning case is the label or the loss
function as a feedback to the
intelligence system and the intelligence
system using SGD would update the skill
program for the next step okay so at
each step the intelligence system can
update the skill program that's why the
intelligent system in this case is the
architecture of the neural network and
the procedure to update the weights not
the weights themselves but the procedure
to update the weights and the skill
program here those would be the actual
weights of the neural network or like
the instantiation of the ResNet with
these particular weights okay now at
test time we sever this connection right
here so this this is now severed at test
time at some point the training is done
the task says okay now training is done
and then the intelligent system will
produce one last skill program and then
this connection is cut and the skill
program must by itself answer to these
situations it cannot like the
intelligent system cannot intervene
anymore and in this loop here it
situation response situation responds
this goes over for a number of steps and
all the scores during that time are
counted and tallied up and at the end
you know the higher the score
better so the intelligence system must
at this end step produce a skill program
that by itself can achieve a high score
ok so there's always this training phase
first and then there is the test phase
now the training phase these situations
that we get in a training phase they are
called
a curriculum in this in this world in
our world this would be something like a
training data set but this this is
curricula it's a slightly more intricate
but just the notion here makes sense
right the intelligent system produces
the skill program ok so there's a lot of
formalisms right here like ok the task
has like a situation generator and that
map's the task state to a situation so
the task can have a state and the skill
program can have a state and the
intelligent system can have a state and
I don't like this is all a bit too
formal you don't really need to
understand it except if Francois Shola
is watching this I think I have found
I'm not sure if it's a mistake but M you
say the intelligent system here consists
of three objects so it generates the
skill program according to its internal
state ok and it generates the skill
program and when it learns when it
learns it updates the internal scale
internal state according to let me if I
can find it right here a self update
function so this is how the intelligent
system can update itself so its own
state so it takes the internal state of
the intelligent system and outputs
another internal state and this is the
you know where I said the internal the
intelligent system at each training step
it can observe what happens and
basically react accordingly
so it takes this situation the response
and the feedback and its own internal
state as an input now what do we have
here it takes the situation which would
be in our case
the training sample the response or the
the log its that the net neural network
has produced the feedback which is the
loss and its internal state okay now
what I argue is basically that it should
also get the internal state of the skill
program as an input right here because
the skill program can have an internal
state all of this like the response can
be a stochastic procedure of the skill
program and I guess it's not necessary
because you can sort of infer it but I
think the framework would be more
complete if the internal state of the
skill program at that time were part of
the intelligent system update procedure
just you don't okay this is not relevant
this is just me bickering cool let's
actually jump all of this this is boring
this is very boring okay bla bla bla bla
bla lots of definitions alright
quantifying generalization difficulty
experience and priors using algorithmic
information theory so these things that
at the beginning we said that we want to
define intelligence with respect to we
are now going to quantify using
algorithmic information theory
algorithmic information theory in this
case right here that we're using it's
not very complicated the main quantity
is this age the algorithmic complexity
at the age of s is the length of the
shortest description of the string in a
fixed universal language okay so it's
the length of the shortest program that
outputs the string when running on a
fixed universal Turing machine so
basically if if you have this string s
right here as is a bit string the
shortest program that can compute s or
you know so so in the worst case that's
the string itself but if the string is
like 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 all the way you can
just say 0 1 times 50 and that's that
would be like the shortest
to produce that it is an it is an
information theoretic concept here but
in essence you can just think of it as a
measure of how long is the program that
I would need to write to output a given
to produce a given output okay so that's
the algorithmic complexity and then the
second quantity right here is the
relative algorithmic complexity which is
almost the same thing it's how long is
the program that I have to write so the
shortest we're always talking about how
long is the shortest program that I have
to write that produces s1 but is allowed
to take s2 as an input okay so it can
never it it can always ignore s2 that's
always a possibility so if s1 is like a
super-easy string you can just output
that but if s1 let's say s2 here is 0 1
0 0 1 ok and s1 is 0 1 0 0 1 0 1 0 0 1
ok so it's just twice that so you could
you could sort of output that string
here you could write a program that just
outputs this or you could write a
program that just says 2 times s2
ok so that the the length of this is not
part of the program the program is just
2 times s2 because it's allowed to take
s2 as an input ok so this is the
algorithmic the relative algorithmic
complexity is how how much how long is
the how complex is the program to get
from s2 to s1 and so you can almost
already see how that will relate now to
to generalization ok so a few quantities
that we need to consider our task called
T here then Seoul T theta is the
shortest of all possible solutions of T
so task T has a solution of threshold
theta which the threshold theta is just
the
is like the minimum score we need to
achieve in a task we don't we consider
tasks according to thresholds like you
know you need to get a I don't know a
score of 9000 in pong or so so the
shortest of all programs that will will
optimize that will solve the task to a
threshold T sorry theta which is a
shortest scale program that achieves at
least theta during evaluation and the
other quantity is this trained sole opt
T C this has a lot of quantity right
here you can see the task we want to be
optimal but with respect to a curriculum
ok the curriculum is the training data
so this quantity is the shortest optimal
training time solution given a
curriculum so it's the shortest scale
program that achieves optimal training
time performance over the situation in
the curriculum so this this right here
is if we could if we had an Oracle that
told us here is how to solve the task in
general like the task of the task of of
determining cats from dogs in images
this this is this is this would be the
program that does it okay you know over
all over the entire the entirety of the
task all cats and dog images there there
are that's the solution now this
quantity right here means sort of the
the one neural network that is best at
disturb determining cats from dogs in
this particular training data set this
curriculum see ok so this is the the one
neural network that is hyper optimized
in this particular training data set and
now we assess the generalization
difficulty so the generalization
difficulty is going to be a measure of
how hard is it to in a particular
tasks it to generalize to the whole task
from the curriculum see and that's going
to be the relative algorithmic
complexity to go from this quantity to
this quantity both quantities we've just
explained so it basically means if if I
had the perfect solution on the training
data set how much how much more complex
is it to get from that to the perfect
solution on the entire T of data or you
can also guess on the test data set so
if if this is really easy so if the
training data set already perfectly
captures all of the data there is that
this quantity is zero
like the out the program I don't need to
write a program I already have the
solution right and you can see here we
divide by the age of salty but however
if the training data has no information
whatsoever about about the about the
solution to the general task or if I
just saw horribly over fit on the
training data such that it doesn't help
me at all
for the general task then this quantity
is zero so this quantity is in zero one
with with sorry the quantity is one of
course yes because the shortest this
thing up here will be equal to just H of
salty because this doesn't help me in
that case and then this ratio will be 1
so generalization difficulty of 1
basically means that the training data
solution doesn't help me at all this
this particular training curriculum is
useless because I'll just over fit so
horribly that I will not learn anything
about the task or I can't learn anything
at all and generalization difficulty of
0 oh that's yeah no yes generalization
difficulty of 0 basically means that all
of the solution is already contained in
the training
solution and I require nowhere could you
get to the to the test set solution okay
this is I mean I do this train test that
this is all a bit more general as it is
written here but I think it's a good a
good way to think about it okay so the
point here he makes is that is that so
yeah he makes this example right here
where he has these two data points where
X minus 0.75 has a label of false and X
the point 1 5 has a label true and the
shortest possible solution will not help
you to generalize to the to the other
things so the nearest neighbor program
would be better prepared for future
uncertainty but would take significantly
more space to write down so there's a
trade-off there's direct trade off to
how much you optimize on the training
data and how much generalization
capability you have okay so the next
quantity we want to assess is developer
aware generalization difficulty because
so far we've only considered
generalization difficulty with respect
to the task itself and to the to the
curriculum but what you could do is you
could simply you know you producing this
intelligent system you could simply
build in the solution to the entire task
into your intelligent system that means
it could completely ignore the training
data and still perform pretty well on
this thing even though even though the
training data itself the algorithmic
complexity it tells you nothing about
about this so the generalization
difficulty would be very high in the
measure up here but so you would think
wow this intelligent system solves this
task really well but it's because you've
baked the solution to the task into the
system and it just ignores the training
data and so the developer aware
generalization difficulty
is going to capture that and basically
punish you for building the solution the
final solution directly into the task so
this is the intelligent system right
here at time zero this is basically
whatever you pre build into the
intelligent system this is it hasn't
interacted with the training data yet
this is simply the state at the very
beginning so this is all the priors you
build in if you build a resonate you
know it has certain you know it has
convolutional filters and so on that's a
certain prior on the translational
invariance if you build a an alphago a
system that certainly has the rules of
go built in to the system and it has
this Monte Carlo tree search which
biases it towards a certain kind of
learning and so on so all of this is
captured in this quantity right here
this basically means that how if I am
given the optimal training solution as
before and also the initial state of the
learning system how much more work is it
to get to the solution of the task and
here you can clearly see if I have
already built the solution into this
system so if I'm building a tic-tac-toe
a earning system I call it a learning
system but I like build in the optimal
strategy from the beginning into my
system and it just ignores the training
data then this thing here would be low
because it takes me it takes me a lot of
work to own with I only have the
training data to get to the solution but
it takes me very little work if I also
have the initial state of the system
because the solution would be encoded
into the initial state already right so
any prior you put in there will be
captured by this okay so otherwise it's
the same the same metric zero means it's
very easy to generalize to the entire
solution one means it's even like it's
given the training data solution and the
system you
me that it is very hard for that system
now consider here this quantity actually
depends on the system you put in all
right then we need two more things which
are priors and experience so this was
the difficulty this was how difficult is
the task as such if for a given system
and a curriculum now what we want we
want to characterize priors and
experience now priors are pretty easy
what are what is a prior a prior we can
capture by simply looking at the
difference between how complex is the
solution - how complex is the solution
if I'm given the initial state this is
almost the same as before but it now
only considers what you built into the
system right there is no training data
anymore it simply says if I have you
know if you give me your source code of
your learning system can i if I can
already read out the solution then this
quantity right here will be zero there
is zero complexity to get from your
initial state of the learning system to
the solution of the task and therefore
this entire quantity would be 1 that
means the prior all the information is
in the prior however if your learning
system is a very general learning system
like it's a it's like a standard
reinforcement learning algorithm with
almost no assumption about the data then
this quantity right here would be very
low so it would be very high of course
because the initial system doesn't tell
you too much so it's still a lot of work
if you gave you the source code is that
well this is very general this doesn't
tell me anything about the task and it
would require a lot of work to get the
dissolution of the task and therefore
the quantity up here would be very low
and therefore this would be close to
zero
so that means there are no priors
in this intelligent system for that
given task okay and the quantity is
always of how to reach the threshold the
solutions always with respect to a
threshold in skill so you must reach
like this many points okay
the important thing that surely notes
here is that the priors captured not
it's not the amount of information in
the progra in the intelligent system but
the amount of relevant information for
that task you can make a super duper
complex intelligent system it's the only
thing that matters for this quantity is
the amount of information that's
relevant to get to the solution of the
task T the last thing we need to capture
is experience not experience basically
means how how much during this learning
phase from now we just talked about at
the at the at the outset like the state
at time zero for the priors
now you remember we interact with the
task for a number of time in this
training phase right and the question is
of course if we are given a longer
training phase it is easier to
generalize generally right in more
training data makes it makes our life
easier makes it easier to generalize and
the intelligence is is inverse
proportional to that so a system that
had all else being equal that has less
training data but is performing as well
on a task as a system that had more
training data that system that had less
training data we consider to be a more
intelligent system because it can
generalize more efficiently so we need
to quantify experience and experience
now in the same kind of in the same
train of thought is going to be the
difference between two quantities so the
first quantity is this so here we
consider at each time step T okay so at
each time step T we have the intelligent
system
we have this thing here called data now
data is everything that the intelligent
system gets at that point in time so in
the intelligent system is here at time
step T and then it outputs this skill
program and that skill program gets a
situation and gives a response and this
gives a feedback and all of this data
that's called data ok it's basically you
can think of it as one additional
training example right you're at time
step T and you're given one additional
training example the experience is going
to quantify how much information is in
that one additional example ok that's
and the and then we're going to sum this
up over time down here which basically
means over the entire course of training
which is this curriculum see how much
information did you get out of the
training data at each step ok that's
going to be your experience over the
course of training which and this is the
sum over the experience that you got at
each step and the experience at each
step is simply the following two things
we're going to assess is how difficult
is it at time T so you've learned 40
steps how difficult is it to go from
that to the solution right so if you you
might have had some training data right
and you you score a certain you score a
certain you look score like 80% on the
on the test set so that's basically how
difficult it is it's it's like you makes
you still make twenty percent of error
that's your difficulty and then you get
one more training sample this data here
now you can ask again if I know
everything I'm knowing my intelligence
system but I also get one more training
data point can I how easy is it now to
arrive at the solution of the task and
now you can say oh with this training
data point
I now can correct some of my mistakes
and
make like 18 percent of error okay so
the difference here would be like two
percent so that's going to be your
experience is going to be worth of two
percent of errors okay now the important
thing here is that it is it is different
if we we could have just written here
minus H of you know so theta T given the
intelligent system at time step T plus
one right because the intelligent system
at times that P plus one has had that
data point at time step T and
incorporated it but that's not that's
not the same thing here we in in this
step right here when we say how
difficult is it we assume that you know
God or vapnik himself tells us how like
the optimal way to use that information
okay
whereas this thing here then it's not a
given that the intelligent system will
use that information in the most optimal
way so this is basically the difference
between how difficult is it to get from
the intelligent system to the solution
and how difficult is it to get from the
intelligent system and the data point at
time T if you could make optimal use of
that data point to the solution alright
so this this is going to be an
assessment of how much experience you've
had in the in the sense of had you been
able to incorporate the experience
properly at each time step okay because
yeah because otherwise you know you you
couldn't compare the experience if two
systems had had the same experience in
the same task it should mean they had
had the same you know data points in the
same order in in a simplistic sense
alright so this is all we need
intelligence boom this is it so there's
a lot of stuff here okay
intelligence of an intelligent system
with respect to a scope and there are
two definitions right here one is for
demo skill at each task and one is for
threshold of skill now we're going to
focus on the threshold as we said we at
each task we require something like you
must achieve a 8,000 points and we're
going to consider the shortest programs
that we'll get to at least 8,000 points
now there's a bit of confusion in the
notation here as this I'm pretty sure
this quantity right here you know should
be called something different because
it's you know it's it the T is here and
then there's this here this refers to
this and this shouldn't be out of here
this should be meaning something like
Thresh I'm pretty sure this is just a
name like here the name opt so yeah in
any case the the intelligence is of an
intelligent system with respect to a
scope of tasks okay and the first thing
we do is we're going to average over the
tasks in the scope so we consider all
the different tasks and each task has a
weight associated with it this this is
the threshold and skill that we want and
this is sort of a mapping this is a
conversion rate because this might be
you know 9000 points at pong and another
task might be you need to achieve 0.2
and that's really good a point 2 is
really good so this w for each task is
simply going to map it to a like a
uniform coordinate space of of all
points of skill level of that particular
task ok so but we're going to average
over tasks
now you can I guess disregard this this
is not super this is just scaling we're
going to average over tasks now in each
task we're going to consider all
curriculums that get you to this
threshold so all curriculums that get
you to the threshold t4 theta T for task
team which means sort of means all the
possible permutations of training data
sets for that task right it's more
general than this
we yeah we want to assess all the all
the different ones and as you can see
here there is P of C so this is an
expectation is the probability of that
particular curriculum this is this is
the expectation over data right here
this is the expectation over the
training data distribution okay in the
classical machine learning sense so
we're gonna take the average across all
tasks over the expectation under the
training data distribution so we're good
so far and usually right here we would
put something like the empirical risk
right a minimum minimum loss min loss
function min theta a loss function over
my term over my C over my training data
set okay but not in this case
because we now want to consider the
priors and the experience and discount
that from the difficulty and that's
what's written here so this is the
developer aware generalization
difficulty this here is the amount of
information that's already contained the
priors and this here is the amount of
information that's contained in the
experience in that curriculum as you can
see here the experience is in that
curriculum so basically a system is more
intelligent if the task is harder for
that given system and that given
curriculum okay so that makes
intelligence of a system is more
intelligent if it gets to a certain
threshold with lower priors okay if the
priors are low this whole quantity is
high and the system is also more
intelligent if it gets to the threshold
with less experience okay so if the
experience here is lower it counts as
more intelligent alright in this in this
quantity and this is written all in the
text here it has some
properties in that it for example it it
down values actors that for in the same
curriculum like in the same training
data they if an actor learns faster like
it learns earlier to reach the threshold
it would assign more intelligence to
that actor and so on it's kind of
sometimes it's hidden over the it's
hidden in the definitions for example
these curricula are not all the same at
the curricular specifically curricula
that you need to reach this certain
threshold so it's not always doesn't
always sum up to one with this
probability that's why it's not exactly
an expectation let's call it an
expectation in quotation marks but in
the general sense that's it
so insist the intelligence of a system
is over a scope of tasks the expectation
in quotation marks under the training
distribution of the generalization
difficulty account but accounted for
discount we discount the prior knowledge
of the system and the experience that
the system has had okay and that's it it
says P plus E prior suppose experience
represents the total exposure of the
system to information about the problem
including the information it starts with
at the beginning of training okay so if
this is high then the system is not very
intelligent or is not if a system that
has more of this but generalizes to the
same level as another system is
considered less intelligent than the
other system because it has had more
exposure to information about the
problem like it it makes a lot of sense
right so schematically the contribution
of each task is the expectation over
skill times generalization divided by
priors plus experience that's kind of in
words what we looked at
so it gives over a number of key
observations and at last he goes over
consequences or basically a a
recommendation for what a benchmark
should look like if we regard it in this
light now of course these complexities
and so on they're not exactly computable
right so it's like how much exactly the
shortest the length of the shortest
program is is not exactly computable but
it can inform our notion of how we
should test intelligence okay so what to
expect of an ideal intelligence
benchmark first of all it should
describe its scope of application its
own predictiveness with regard to this
scope so that means the validity it
should be replicable it should be
reproducible it should measure broad
abilities and developer aware
generalization sorry it should it should
set out to measure broad abilities and
developer aware generalization okay so
that means it should not be solely
measuring skill or potential it should
not feature in its evaluation set any
tasks that are known in advance either
to the test-taking system itself or to
the developers of the system and that of
course refers directly to the developer
aware generalization and it should seek
to quantify the generalization
difficulty it measures or at least
provide qualitative guidelines with
regards to its generalization difficulty
it should at least be made clear whether
the benchmark seeks to measure local
generalization broad generalization or
extreme generalization so we've we've
seen this in part one taking into
account generalization difficulty
minimizes the possibility that a given
benchmark could be hacked by solvers
that take undesired shortcuts that
bypass broad abilities okay it says it
should control for the amount of
experience leveraged by test-taking
systems during training it
not be possible to buy performance on
the benchmark by sampling unlimited
training data so this this already rules
out sort of any let's say image
recognition or NLP benchmarks because
there we can always just feed in more
dates of the more unlabeled data from
the internet or even labeled data like
if there is a benchmark that you know is
on computer vision I can just pay more
humans to label more data and then I
will be better at that benchmark the
benchmark should avoid tasks for which
new data can be generated at will it
should be in effect a game for which it
is not possible to practice in advance
of the evaluation session that's going
to be hard right it should be it should
explicitly and exhaustively desert
describe the set of priors it assumes
any task is going to involve priors but
in many tasks used for AI evaluation
today
priors stay implicit and the existence
of implicit hidden priors may often give
an unfair advantage to either humans or
machines so this is for example if the
test is like a speed test a lot of times
machines are going to be way faster than
humans because the hidden assumption in
a speed test is that kind of your nerve
conductivity is the same across all test
takers and the last one it should work
for both humans and machines fairly by
only assessing the same priors as
possessed by humans and it refers to
core knowledge which we saw in the last
part and only requiring a human-sized
amount of practice time or training data
so this means if we want to compare
humans and machines machines can often
incorporate way more data than humans
so the tasks in the benchmark should
only like the amount of data should be
such that a human could process that
data now of course that that sort of
also means that any task where basically
you collect data during your life is all
also sort of ruled out a bit so that
means the AI benchmark task can't be
like cook
pan of spaghetti or something like this
yeah and in the end he says these
recommendations for general AI
evaluation wouldn't be complete without
a concrete effort to implement them in
part three we present our initial
attempt which is going to be the arc
data set and the arc cackle challenge
but that's a story for next time I hope
you enjoy this and at least got some
bits of it it's very abstract this
measure of intelligence of course it can
never be computed exactly but the fact
that someone is trying to formalize and
it's not the first time this has been
trying to formalize but this I feel it's
quite understandable and it makes sort
of sense and um I'm interested to see if
if people come up with expert like
actual approximations to this quantity
that you could actually compute sort of
alright that was it
thank you for watching and bye bye see
you next time